welcome to the machine learning Street
talk YouTube channel with me the X
Microsoft tech lead dr. Tim scarf Conor
shortened and Yannick Kilcher today is a
special episode we have Jourdan Edwards
principal program manager on the Azure
machine learning team Jordan has almost
single-handedly transformed the
reputation of Azure ml into an
enterprise ready credible platform for
doing machine learning DevOps
DevOps is all about people process and
platforms to enable continuous delivery
of value to your end-users it's about
accelerating the velocity of software
deployments it's about taking all of the
friction out of the process to help you
be more entrepreneurial to help you fail
fast to create data science labs and
environments automatically with
infrastructure as code if you view
machine learning as a software
engineering discipline there is a
specialization of interests and
expertise across the life cycle there
are data scientists there are engineers
there are ops people there are
governance people machine learning is
the next generation of software
engineering now we shouldn't be
hyperbolic about machine learning it's
not really intelligence it's just a
computer program with mo DevOps we can
treat the machine learning lifecycle
exactly the same way as we do for
software engineering but there's a key
difference machine learning produces a
lot more technical debt in production
than traditional software so there's a
lot more things we need to do we need to
think about governance at the company
level we need to think about the
handshake between all the different
personas and the software engine life
cycle we need to think about ethics and
fairness we need to think about machine
learning engineering and testing in the
interactive phase and the non
interactive phase data scientists
famously like to work in Jupiter
notebooks which is antithetical to
software engineering and for a long time
I thought that the best solution was to
get the data scientist to behave like
software engineers I've now been
thoroughly disavowed of that persuasion
figuring out ways to get the very
different stakeholders in this process
to work together effectively is one of
the key challenges of ML DevOps I really
enjoyed talking to Jordan Edwards a key
driver to innovation and machine
learning is the velocity of our
iteration cycles autonomy of data
scientists and being able to get models
into production machine learning is just
like software but it produces more
technical debt in production the models
might make important decisions and
therefore need to have rigorous testing
and governance ml DevOps is about
orchestrating the non interactive phase
of software deployments for machine
learning this is extremely hard to get
right because of the different personas
involved in the lifecycle of model
deployments
this is Formula one in the 1950s as you
can see it was a manual error-prone
process they were engineers hitting
parts of the car with hammers there was
no monitoring and their automation this
is what Formula one looks like today
there are many different types of
engineer working together effectively
it's fast it's continuously monitored
and improved the whole process has been
automated and orchestrated this is a
machine learning DevOps
mo DevOps is all about increasing the
velocity of software deployments it's
about reducing all of the friction out
of the process to help people in the
organization fail fast to go from vision
to value and to take exciting ideas
around machine learning and get them
into production we've had this horrible
problem for years now it's called data
science myopia and that is that models
are created in Jupiter notebooks and
they don't go anywhere and it's
impossible to do governance at the
company level because there's such a
complex interaction between all of the
specialized roles in the data science
process this is what mo DevOps is for
it's about orchestrating the interactive
and the non interactive phase of
software deployments it's also about
testing and monitoring for example with
the data scientists might create
interactive explain ability tests to
understand what the model is doing a
machine learning engineer might create a
non-interactive semantic test to test
the model behavior there might also be
load tests integration
and so on one of the other things we
look at is Jordans mo DevOps maturity
model and this is super interesting
because I think mo DevOps can become an
intellectual exercise and no progress is
made so I think it's really valuable to
come up with a maturity model so there
in your company you can have different
projects in flights that are at
different levels of maturity and that's
established governance is one of the
things that interests me the most so
many models that we put into production
may have life threatening decisions of
consequence in which case we need to
have a structured process to decide what
kind of explain ability we need whether
or not we should use machine learning at
all maybe we need an expert system and
what kind of check-in process should we
have throughout the lifecycle of a
machine learning project mo DevOps also
allows us to have this entrepreneurial
fail-fast culture in business it means
that a business person can spin up a
data science lab we can template eyes
previous solutions that we've already
created we can ingest data from an
analytical data store like our data Lake
maintaining our role-based access
control and all of our data governance
procedures my dream is that people in
the business can create a data science
lab by saying ma locks in it they can
scaffold the project they can say I want
to have a structured project I want to
have this kind of production target I
want to have this kind of environment I
want to have this kind of governance
process I want to have this kind of
explain ability and we can scaffold that
in to end and remove all of the friction
out of the process that's the dream that
we want to achieve with mo DevOps as a
researcher usually whenever I have
trained the model that performs really
well my job is done I'm happy and this
is all good but Jordans job only starts
at that point he takes these models that
researchers produce and tries to get
them to production his team basically
does anything that you need to get a
machine learning pipeline up running
reproducible and up to scale to ship it
out how to make machine learning into a
real product that's kind of the topic of
our talk today and I was super excited
to learn about a site that I
never get to see otherwise haha
we had Microsoft build a couple of weeks
ago as well and the folks at Microsoft
released some pretty interesting stuff
relating to machine learning first of
all they released something called
Microsoft seal this is something that
they've been working on since about 2012
it's all about homomorphic encryption
seal is an open-source homomorphic
encryption toolkit allowing machine
learning to be performed directly on
encrypted data this means data can be
shared and worked on securely by remote
data scientists Microsoft have also
released something called fair learn
which is a set of Python packages for
assessing and evaluating and also
implementing fairness in your machine
learning approaches fair learn a package
that empowers developers of AI systems
to assess their systems fairness and
mitigate any unobserved unfairness
issues interpret ml is an open source
library for creating explainable and
fair and machine learning models on
structured and text data and finally
Microsoft have released something called
white noise which is all about
differential privacy white noise is a
toolkit that offers strong privacy
assurances preventing data leaks and re
identification of individuals in a data
set so white noise will add a little bit
of noise to some of your records which
means it will no longer be possible to
determine whether a certain record
influenced the model which is super
important for privacy Microsoft
announced further work on the zero
redundancy optimizer with gradient and
activation memory implementations in 0-2
Microsoft's blog post claimed this
optimization it support rating a 200
billion parameter language model a week
later open a I blew the machine learning
world out of the water by actually
building such a model train to this
infrastructure GPT 3 has 175 billion
parameters Microsoft had invested 1
billion dollars into open AI last year
and we're starting to see some really
cool projects as a result of the
collaboration only yesterday GPT 3 was
announced by open AI now last year
Microsoft put a billion dollars of
investment into open AI and this is
where some of the money is going
Yanik did a really great video on the
speed and zero - it wouldn't have been
possible to train this GPT three model
if it wasn't for the innovations that
have come out of Microsoft that have
allowed them to train these ridiculously
big
AI models so GPT - had about 11 billion
parameters in and Microsoft's project
Turing had 17 billion parameters and
this new model has a hundred and seventy
five billion parameters now Yannick did
a really good video talking through the
ins and outs of GPT three and admittedly
it's a little bit like a memorization
machine it's an incredibly good hash
table that can look up and find all of
the bits of text it was trained on and
it can cleverly interpolate between them
it was incredibly expensive to train
this thing but it just goes to show
there are some amazing things we can do
now especially using zero shot one shot
and few shot learning additionally
another collaboration with open AI
showcased the remarkable code completion
ability of large language models trained
on code completing functions with just
the function name and a doc string as
input
now we covered a lot of ground of Jordan
today we talked about some of the build
announcements we talked about a machine
learning being the next generation of
software engineering and how we can do
things like infrastructure as code to
take the friction out of machine
learning how we can do governance at the
company level how we can do automated
testing and also we had some interesting
ideas about interpretability and how we
should do the handoff between
interactive testing and non interactive
testing I hope you enjoy the episode
today remember to Like comment and
subscribe and we'll see you back next
week
welcome back to the machine learning
Street Talk YouTube channel with me Tim
scarf my compadres Yannick Kilcher
Connor shorten and today we have an
incredible guest we've got Jordan
Edwards I've known Jordan for several
years I used to work with Jordan when I
was at Microsoft and he's extremely well
thought of inside Microsoft I think it's
no exaggeration to say that Jordan has
pretty much single-handedly transformed
the perception of Azure machine learning
into a credible enterprise ready
platform for doing mo DevOps so it's
super cool to have Jordan on with us
today so welcome Jordan thanks for
having me damn awesome so why don't you
tell us a bit about what you do and your
story at Microsoft sure
so I'm Jordan Edwards I'm a product
manager on the Azure machine learning
team and I work on what we call ml ops
or how do you bring your machine
learning workflows to production so bit
of background for me I started at
Microsoft around almost eight years ago
now in July and I started off by working
on the Bing platform doing you know
distributed systems application
middleware business logic tear things
like that evolved from that into working
on engineering systems so spend some
time as a product manager some time as a
developer I started working on
engineering systems helped move the Bing
organization as well as the office
organization over to using git and using
you know cloud-based build systems and
really introduced the culture of CI CD
to these ml first organizations now as I
was doing that you know came to realize
that you know while this problem or that
has been well largely solved or there
are tons of tools available for
developers the tooling that's in place
for data scientists is much more
primitive and also we find that many
data scientists are coming in have more
of a research background and aren't
classically trained as software
engineers so the tools are slightly
different you know they were trained to
publish papers and not to write programs
and so as part of that and it did some
more investigation sat with some data
scientists inside and outside of
Microsoft just to learn their ways of
working and started formulating a
strategy for how can we take some of the
tooling that we've been building in
Azure and in the Bing platform and
around the company and bring it together
into a cohesive story to enable what we
were calling like DevOps for MLA I at
the time and then
has slowly evolved as the marketing
terms have developed into what is you
know ml ops and that's been a big big
collaboration across the companies so
we've you know been working with the
azure data team at the developer tools
developer division and trying to make
sure that we have a cohesive story for
how you can wire up your data pipelines
your data catalog your model development
or training pipelines your model
registry and then your existing you know
software development lifecycle
application release management tools so
it's like how do you really complete the
loop because the big the big Delta
compared to you know classical software
engineering is you bring in data
engineers data scientists data models
and things yet way more complicated
really fast that's yeah I have like an
infinite amount of questions so so first
I really want to kind of dive into how
how it looks because for most people
maybe listening or something like this
like you either have the the university
researcher right that maybe works on on
these models and so on or I'm still
going to guess that most data scientists
are actually you know doing fairly basic
data analysis and so on so I think not
many people in the world right now are
doing what you're doing like actually
build big products with state-of-the-art
kind of machine learning so how how
large is actually the the machine
learning model what how large of a part
of just your effort is that or is it
like is it mainly there's 5% of work
going into the actual model and then 95%
needs to be built around it or right and
how does it really yeah it really varies
based on the customer and the scenario
so some customers will come to us and
say I have some data and I want to do
forecasting on it right and like I don't
have any machine learning data science
background but I have this
data that's at least shaped in tabular
form and so how do I you know at least
you know try to get a model out and see
if the models any good embed the model
into a business application and then
figure out you know the the trickiest
part is okay I've got this model unlike
normal software you can't keep a model
around forever right like they tend to
have some seasonality or properties of
decay to them it's like how do I figure
out when I need to create a new model to
replace it so you know we come you know
in all of the talks that I have with big
customers it's like okay here are the
you know here's this process maturity
model for the machine learning lifecycle
here's stages one two three and four and
the usual response I get is like well
we're at phase zero like we have we have
none of this so and and a lot of that
too comes with it's not even necessarily
the about the tooling it's more about
the people and the process and this is
we saw the same thing with DevOps as
well right like anybody can go and
stitch together open-source tools to set
up a machine learning platform but if
the process and the people and the roles
and responsibilities aren't set up ahead
of time you're just gonna end up with
what is more or less a disaster where
you've got you know data scientists have
a bunch of like CSVs pulled down onto
their laptops the way they've trained
the models like even they can't figure
out how they produced it they've got a
pickle file sitting somewhere and then
they go talk to their dev and say hey
I've got a model and they're like what
is this thing how do I use this so these
are the the sets of problems that we
really want to want to go after as much
as possible and so from a like product
strategy point of view the first thing
is okay let's look at how data
scientists are working today so we have
there's this kind of two different
schools of data science we've seen you
have the folks who are really big on
notebooks and you have the and those
tend to be more of your like researchers
doing data science and then you have I
call them AI developers but it's
basically software engineers who are
doing machine learning and it
they send anymore you know IDE users so
you've got your your notebook users and
your IDE users they have very different
styles and ways of working and so how do
you build a solution that can capture
and help make the model development
process group reducible for both of
those flows so that's sort of the
biggest pain point we're trying to go
after and tackle right now that's super
interesting I think we'll get on to the
dichotomy between science and
engineering shortly the articulate some
of the goals that I see for ML DevOps I
think it's squarely about seeing machine
learning is the next generation of
software engineering so that's not
necessarily about these there are some
data scientists that are just doing data
science on their own machine
interactively we're not talking about
that we're talking about that road to
production so in my opinion that goes of
mo DevOps it's about increasing the
velocity of software deployments it's
about increasing the quality and
security of software orchestrating the
non interactive phase of software
engineering and the handover between the
interactive fresh and the non
interactive phase it's allowing
companies to develop this kind of
entrepreneurial culture where they can
go from vision to value they can fail
fast we'll talk in a little while about
template izing and being able to use
infrastructure as code and spin up data
science labs and so on it's about
introducing governance and continuous
monitoring and having risk management
for governance or something at that I
think we can talk about soon as well
because some models need to be
verbalized able some model ready to be
explainable and there should be some
kind of a process that manages that
putting guardrails there sometimes it's
very important because we're coming on
to the really big thing here which is
this is bigger than any one person or
team or projects if there is a web of
accountability and one of the big things
with DevOps is managing the handshakes
between different personas involved in
this software engineering lifecycle and
there is a specialization isn't there of
interest and expertise that the data
scientist does not care about governance
and the the ops person doesn't know
anything about data science and the data
scientist might know about building
models but might not know about being
doing the kind of area testing that an
mo engineer might do so with the best
will in the world even if you're a
unicorn and you can do almost everything
you probably
really we need to orchestrate exactly
yeah and there there is no you know one
man shop to do production Enterprise ml
and like you talked about many things
but you didn't even bring up you know
the whole responsible AI responsible ml
part of it which is you know say I'm
building a model for a financial
institution how do I guarantee that
model is not you know discriminating and
certain user verbs like bringing
responsibility into the picture and
fairness is is also super important so
yeah anybody's the governance the
governance bucket yeah it's it's a
bigger question right it's like how do
you how do you verify or how do you do
Quality Assurance ran a software that
you basically have no clue how it's
working right especially if we go into
the more deep learning areas of machine
learning you don't know and how do you
so how does how does something like just
something basic like unit testing you
know continuous continuous testing and
so on how does that work going from
staging - you know beta to actual
release is it just you have these bunch
of test sets and if it scores well then
it gets through or how do people I mean
then that's sort of the most primitive
way of doing it is you brute force it
with your golden set of test data to
validate that it works well across all
the scenarios you'd expect but we have a
bunch of tooling that we've been working
on in the open-source community some of
like the interpret ml stuff for you
bring in shap and lime and you know as
you're training the model you try to
figure out which features are being used
the relative importance of those
features and you know you can do some
fuzzing and bias busting where even in
the case of deep learning you can remove
just remove one signal and see how that
changes the output of the model right so
say I just take color out of an image
for example and see how that changes
what what the model creates yeah that
that's super interesting and I'd love
for us to drill into this a tiny bit yes
there are so many different tests
the lifecycle of production writing
these models now on interpretability the
Yannick famously said a few weeks ago
that he thought it was like reading tea
leaves I'm fascinated by it for example
I interviewed Marco Rubio he created
life on my YouTube channel and the idea
is that you come up with a semantically
relevant perturbations and then you
build a linear model and you figure out
which of those perturbations flips the
switch on a classifier but the problem
is many of these methods are open to
interpretation and especially on
unstructured models if you're using
these methods on language and vision
model Rea they may require another model
just to classify whether or not they do
what you want I've been developing this
idea that I think interpretability
methods are useful in the interactive
phase but they're not necessarily in the
non interactive phase and so you can
have a blended approach and this is why
I think we need to have some kind of
model risk management process which will
take into account the unique
circumstances of every single model to
give you an example yeah in banking when
they do credit decisions if you apply
for a credit card they won't use a model
they'll use an expert system and the
reason is it needs to be explainable but
not in the sense that you would think it
you need to be able to verbalize why
it's doing what it's doing so they use
an expert system and they say what's
your net credit balance and how many
defaults have you had in the last 12
months and it's code it's an expert
system so no machine learning model is
explainable it's not verbalize aboard
you can explain the what but you can't
explain the how so surely then there are
there are certain cases where you need
to have an expert system and then there
are some cases that have less severity
where you would use explained ability
yeah I'd totally agree and I think that
you know training time fairness analysis
yeah bias busting that's where the tools
that we have right now are most useful
unfortunately a lot of times when the
model is actually running in production
it's it's more of a reactive signal
where it's you know either reported or a
labourer comes in and says like no this
is wrong and then you have to feed that
signal back
into the model training process it's
like oh you know this this signal is
being weighted incorrectly or this
signal just needs to be dropped
completely from the training process
that's getting to that degree of
maturity that requires a lot of muscle
and we're still you know just starting
to turn the wheel on that one and that's
that's also why for a lot of many of
these highly regulated institutions have
been very slow to adopt machine learning
and in particular deep learning just
because if you can't explain it no
regulator is going to approve you know
making potentially life-or-death
decisions with a black box well could we
rip on that just for a minute yeah we we
don't require humans to explain how they
know things we can't verbalize how we
know things an aeroplane pilot cannot
tell you how he fly and how he flies the
plane what we do is we do testing and
human intelligence has much broader
generalization so less testing is needed
we can assume with less testing that the
pilot would be able to fly in more
situations deep learning is a bit like a
hash table given a sufficiently good
sampling of the input space there is
some interpolation and and given
sufficient testing we would be able to
infer that the model would run in
production as expected so surely given
the correct amount of testing we could
rely on deep learning models yes
assuming that the case is something the
model has seen before but that's the
best the key thing right great I love
this methodology that Marco Rubio came
up with around doing error testing and
model so he said things like lime and
shopping are great for the the
interactive frame but in the non
interactive phase we need to be building
expert systems to test the models they
need to be able to run as code and the
kind of thing he came up with was if it
was an unstructured problem being able
to turn it into a structured kind of
like a unit test and he had this like
this concept of semantically equivalent
adversarial examples so for example you
could have a rule which would turn what
followed by an hour
into which followed by a noun and then
you would see in your test set did it
flip the switch on more than four
percent of the examples or in the
fairness example you could do data
grouping and you could say well split it
into men and women and is the accuracy
higher on men than women in which case
let's not put this into production so
what we're doing is we're coming up with
expert systems right to determine
whether or not
so I suppose verbalize herbal tests to
determine whether or not something does
or doesn't go into production so we're
taking the magic out of the process and
I think the trick to doing that well and
effectively is having a good semantic
understanding of data in the first place
so one big gap I've seen from lots of
lots of companies and we even have this
problem in Microsoft in some places is
like we just don't have enough labeled
data or enough knowledge of what we're
working on to be able to solve that
because you know for for adversarial
testing your basic example is like okay
so say I'm looking at dogs and cats
right and I'm building it but dog or cat
classifier but like let me throw in you
know a baby now and just see what
happens they're like you throw something
totally out of the blue and see what the
behavior looks like when it's never seen
it before or you could just start
flipping certain signals around like
same for my my you know my dogs sample
it was all golden retrievers right and
then my cat sample is all black cast now
if I feed in a gold-colored cat which
way is it gonna go on the classification
so it's like how do you the semantic
understanding of data is super important
and I think that is where we're gonna
see the most development going forward
especially as we get more advanced on
the simulation side right so when you
can use simulators to generate these
data sets that allow us to test and the
simulator can even apply labels to those
generated test sets that you can then
use for a variety of different
applications so that's I think yeah the
the growth of the data state to include
you know test data for ml is gonna be a
very cool space to watch so do you see
data augmentation playing a huge role in
that like I've seen with like the
dermatology gand paper
they use a pix depicts image to image
translation network so they can have all
the different like skin colors lighting
conditions so do you think like data
augmentation is going to be a huge
workhorse and kind of like balancing out
the data set and then sort of doing this
kind of generalization I think that's
gonna be probably the biggest compute
spinner in the space going forward to
tease you know and and Azure we often
talk about like okay you know this this
problem were working on how much you
compute do we need to solve it but I
think that Jenna yeah generating data
pulling out semantic properties of data
and extracting the layers of data so
that you can look at like you know
layers of something as a feature store
like that's gonna be a very cool problem
space for us to really really hammer on
so sorry is most of this like kinda add
a distribution detection is most of this
still kind of manually encoded like with
the during an example we're manually
saying of like lighting and skin color
and the size of this skin is the key
thing you see like automated added
distribution kind of generalization
metrics being useful in the near future
near future is tough to say it's gonna
depend on on the company like for for
example I would imagine that someone
like Facebook is looking very closely
and how to do this at scale and we can
see that making its way into PI tours
for example as a toolkit to help with
this type of problem but I think that
for you know for now we've seen a lot of
ml work on the tabular side and we're
just scratching the surface when it
comes to whether it's text for NLP or
images or audio or you know video data
which is kind of the the synthesis of
all of these put together right and you
know since we're since we're on a call
now like the problem of how do you do
noise suppression effectively when
you're doing remote calls is a very fun
ml problem where you can think about how
do you pull out you know all the layers
of an audio stream coming in and figure
out which ones are and aren't relevant
in this context like that's that's a
real
a problem that I'm I'm excited by some
of the work we're doing inside Microsoft
and the work that's going on externally
in that space in terms of compute how I
don't know if you've if you've been at
your current position for super-long but
how has how has deep learning changed
the game of this entire let's sell ml
products and so on
it's GPUs everywhere right yeah so I
mean the problem with deep learning I've
seen is a lot of times data scientists
like to try a the newest trendiest thing
and deep learning is overkill for a lot
of these problems like if I'm building
an anomaly detector on a tabular data a
simple like regression or a simple
scikit-learn like classical ML model or
an ensemble of those will probably solve
me this faster and cheaper than a deep
learning model well that's the the base
problem is it's it's it's being used as
too big of a hammer to solve a lot of
these issues but in terms of like the
the usage on the machine learning side
we're definitely it you know well over
half of our machine learning jobs are
using deep learning today do you think
it's different because that a company
like Microsoft's you have access to
these incredible data sets you have
access to all of this compute so it
seems more appropriate I would like to
play devil's advocate to what you said
before because I am a bit of a deep
learning zealot and I am of the opinion
that you can apply it to almost anything
and to a certain extent it's because of
the compositionality of deep learning
you it's like it's a unifying
computational paradigm which means you
can use the same set of ideas and tools
to solve any problem and you can compose
together models a bit like Lego bricks
and you can use some pre trained ones
and you can use some stuff them over
here and stuff them over there
so it's very inviting I can see why
people would think yeah I only need to
have deep learning
of course people talk about the no free
lunch theorem which is basically saying
that you do need to have specialized
algorithms and in order to get the best
out of it it will probably end up there
eventually as the deep learning
frameworks continue to evolve but
definitely right now in turn
of you know ease of entry ease of
getting started like if you're learning
ml starting with classical ml before you
jump off the deep end of the pool it
looks to me also like the no free lunch
thing is still like very much at play
you could imagine network architecture
search data augmentation hyper
parameters learning rate tuning you
could easily have the five percent
difference in tuning the deep learning
model so I think it's still that
automated hyper parameter search still
makes it the no free lunch theorem even
with deep learning right it's also
interesting talk about where you want to
use a deep learning model is the deep
learning model your endgame or is the
deep learning model for example just
being used as a feature Iser we've seen
that be on the automated machine
learning side a nice way to ease
customers into deep learning is throwing
in like bert bert-- encoders as things
that we can run on on text data but i
think the key is going to be not
exposing the inner workings evolve the
derivatives inside of the deep learning
framework to people trying to train
models right away it needs to be
explainable understandable some of that
you're touching on something interesting
though which is one of the reasons why
we've struggled to have an ml DevOps
framework for years is every single ml
DevOps project is different the
computer's heterogeneous you might have
distributed inferencing you might be
doing data engineering effectively using
deep learning models the permutations of
these architectures is mind-blowing ly
large so I'm interested to know how you
get a handle on this really because one
of the things that excites me is I
genuinely want to have a way of template
izing and scaffolding this I want
someone in the business to say I want to
create a data science lab and I want to
have this I want to have this it's an
unstructured problem here's my
analytical data store I want to do this
engineering I want to use this pre-baked
model that someone else has done I want
to have this production ization target
and then it would just create it for me
and then I just check some code in or I
just create my as your ml pipeline then
it will just do it how far away are we
from that we're getting to a better spot
for that we're starting to
I arrived at the point now and you're
seeing you know technologies emerge in
the wild whether it's cube flow ml flow
whatever where the concept of machine
learning pipelines and being able to
define strongly-typed
inputs and outputs two steps in the
pipeline and having the ability to move
those inputs and outputs from one
compute fabric to another like that's
that's getting more more and more fluid
over time because you know a pretty
common scenario as you'll see data
preparation is done on spark right and
then you'll want to use you know GPUs to
actually go and train the model and then
maybe CPUs to evaluate or compare the
two the two Delta's like that's a pretty
common scenario we hear pop up and so
that getting to a clean interoperable
format between different steps in the ml
pipeline is is super important and that
you know when it comes to that so for
example like do we want to go all-in on
Parque or do we think that there is a
different standard we should be looking
at for how to federate data across these
computes then there's also the question
of you know data flows so how do I
design a to look at a patchy beam as an
example right like how do i define a
data flow that can run locally but can
also scale up to to massive scale as I
go beyond like okay I think this model
is good against this you know 0.1% of my
data but now let me try against the full
thing and see what I get so it's it's
heterogeneous compute and it's how do
you scale what was an interactive
experiment to run on your full data
corpus without shooting yourself in the
foot and you know for that's where it
comes in to for each of the compute
targets that you're running on being
able to closely monitor and analyze like
are they using resources effectively you
know like is how much of the time on the
GPU is being wasted right now because
this operation isn't taking advantage of
it like this is all of the fine tuning
that goes into proper ml engineering and
setting up like real end-to-end ml
pipelines
hi I just want to say as a researcher
every single attempt at scaffolding or
whatnot has failed every time there is a
framework that's like oh just plug in
your data here and your model here and
boobity boo and I'm like yeah but now I
want to multiply each data point by two
at this step or gradient from from this
point write it like every every single
time it costs me more to learn the
intrinsics of the model because I want
to do something that the model that the
framework designer hasn't you know
thought of so I need to like okay wait
watch what do i need to sub class right
now it's just it's just kind of painful
every time
yeah it moves too fast right if you're
outside the scope of the operators in
your framework then you're kind of you
know largely stuck and that's where I
actually think docker is particularly
important and useful for machine
learning because with docker and
containers you can actually design a
heterogeneous compute PI plan where you
know sure all of the operators in your
framework can run together in memory
whatever but say I say I want to mix
like tensorflow and PI torch together
right like they have some fundamental
and compatibility so how do I build that
bridge well spin up two containers just
pass the pass the output in an
interoperable format whether you put it
in you know a shared memory bus or you
flush it to the disk whatever but I
think combining containers with
containers running on heterogeneous
compute with an Orchestrator that can
handle that is how you solve this for
real I don't think there's ever gonna be
like an uber framework that has every
operator a data scientist would ever
want to use it's just not realistic
another trade-off is a the dichotomy
between having control and governance
and having freedom and this is part of
what we're getting to with this cultural
dichotomy between science and
engineering when I was at Microsoft I
was surrounded by incredibly gifted and
bright people who were multidisciplinary
they they were data scientist but they
were also brilliant software engineers
so I would be forgiven for having the
the misconception that
we should conflate science and
engineering and my strategy on several
mo DevOps projects was to encourage the
data scientists to be code first to use
IDs to use software engineering tools
like git and C ICD and so on to
participate in in the full lifecycle of
the engineering project and I had some
resistance at the time because people
were saying well these data scientists
they they might be physicists or
something they they might not know
anything about software engineering they
yeah but I was making the argument that
well it shouldn't be any different right
because even if you're if you're
designing a computer science algorithm
you go to a coding interview at Google
what are you doing well you're
whiteboarding it and you're realizing it
and why is data science any different
because the big thing they resist is any
attempt to control the way they work
especially in a scrum methodology
because they see it as a kind of
truncation or censorship of their fluid
process of thinking and so on and I used
to be very madly against that but now
now I kind of I understand it I they are
a different breed of human being had the
same problem as you when I first started
on this too I'm like wait they don't
understand get but it's so easy like
what's going on here but I think what it
finally struck me after spending you
know three or four weeks with just like
embedded with a team of data scientists
and looking at how they work I mean
seriously like it's it's so iterative
and so much of just trying different
things and seeing what sticks it's not
like here's this task go solve it like
go implement this class like that's it's
it's experimental and so the workflow
for interactive experimentation is very
very different than the software
engineering workflow
yeah that's so true but I suppose you
could call it a hypothesis driven
development and it's a it's a different
I think already that the curbs the
different cuz even in software
engineering there's the famous coastline
of Great Britain problem and so that the
coastline has this fractal property so
every time you zoom in there's more
detail so you tend to underestimate the
duration of every software project by a
factor of three and I think for data
science projects is more like a factor
of ten I was saying everybody yeah yeah
even higher in it's because if you ask
10 different data scientist how to solve
a problem they'll give you ten different
answers right and just that the curves
are different if you look at it as a
software engineering project that the
curves are different it's much harder to
predict what's going on I think you have
to look at it as a research project and
I think for most organizations you
really have to have a separation between
your data scientists and your ml
engineers like that's the the other big
miss we've seen is most organizations
don't actually have ml engineers they
have data scientists and software
engineers who can't talk to each other
and that's why they get stuck so you
know we've we've talked to a bunch of
customers now and even helped some of
them kind of right JD's to pull ml
engineers into their organizations
really what you what you want in that
use cases you want you know your your AI
developer so you want a software
engineer who understands DevOps and
understands enough about the ML problem
that they can take what the data
scientist built and operationalize it
right it's it's like a computer
scientist versus a software engineer
it's the same thing so I wanted you to
spend more time talking about what the
ml engineer does because I think this is
the role that if you look in a lot of
industry at the moment they don't have
the notion of an ml engineer sometimes
if you look at some of the vendors
providing machine learning platforms
that they also remove the notion of a
machine learning engineer whereas I
think it if you if you think of a
software engineering project it's
something which accrues technical debts
in fact we're going to talk about this
paper called machine learning the high
interest credit card of technical debt
that's got some super interesting bits
in it well what I would like to do
quickly though is is share my screen and
you've got this wonderful deck where you
talk about a maturity model of a machine
learning so let's just do that
now this is wonderful this is a set of
slides that came from Jordan and I think
this this beautifully articulates a
maturity model from ml ops and the
reason I think this is useful is I think
we run the risk of intellectualizing
this process when we start talking about
ml ops we take it to the nth degree we
start talking about sophisticated risk
governance procedures we start talking
about AI ethics and and legals and
automated retraining and things like the
canary deployments and zero downtime
rollbacks and so on what's so good about
this is you can put a mark in the ground
and you can say well I want to have a
certain level of maturity for this
particular project so level one is know
ml ops this is how we started this is
when a data scientist will look at the
data catalog get some data from an
analytical data store select an
algorithm but what happens next
this is the key problem with ml ops it's
the myopia of the data scientist it's
it's where does the model go after it's
been created so the first thing that we
do here is is we create reproducibility
by automating what the data scientists
have done and this is super interesting
because this slide solves the problem of
what we were talking about before
because we were saying that we want data
scientists to be like software engineers
and rather than trying to force them to
use reproducible software engineering
tools like git and vs code what's
beautiful about this is is as remote has
this concept of a pipeline and it's like
a workflow engine and and that's how we
get the reproducibility because the
pipeline will record their lineage to
the data and the hyper parameters and
the code and so on so the data
scientists from their Jupiter notebook
can create this pipeline interactively
and then it becomes a non interactive
process later on so I think this is the
key thing that solves that problem right
and the cool thing about that too is
that yeah the whole machine learning
pipeline product was a grassroots
in-house effort at Microsoft which was
started to solve a very real problem
which is you had data scientists that
were building models on their laptops
and they wanted to be able to run the
training process somewhere else so it's
like how do I have you know I have this
code here how do I run it somewhere else
how does anybody else run it and how do
I put it into a pipeline without
requiring them to learn like you know
DevOps wasn't even really a thing when
they
first started so they they built the
tool to solve the problem of course they
originally built it you know back before
Python for data science of the thing so
while it was just C++ being stitched
together but then we took that internal
core and kernel and baked it into Azure
ml and you know going forward we're also
trying to look and see how we can take
that that same process flow and logic
and bring it to the open source
community so that we have you know an an
open standard for machine learning
pipelines the meaning is just that if I
have done something once it kind of
records it and it's able to run it again
or is it more of a is it more of a if
new data comes in I can run the same
pipeline find to find a new model us
data scientists won't ever give that up
we can't you can't replace us with a
with a pipeline every model needs needs
its own care from a legal point to be
more than anything else it's a you need
to have reproducibility you need to be
able to lock down how was this model
created I think that's the first thing
and the second thing is in these
retraining workflows we want to be able
to recreate the model again in the
future without the data song right I
think it's directively creating it
exactly it's reproducibility it's also
composability though so the next step I
think Tim will we'll get to this in a
subsequent slide but is okay right so I
have I have that have a reproducible
model now the ml engineer needs to be
able to take that model package it
certify it and then release it to yeah
somewhere right so that could be it's
deployed out and running in a container
on kubernetes it could be it's inside of
a sequel database and is used as part of
a you know a relational query there it
could be it's you know deploy it out to
your phone and it's used it's being used
for augmented reality or it's being used
for you know
background noise suppression and when
you're talking to somebody
so that's that's the the cool space is
when you bring in hey I have the model
registry I have the pipeline that
trained the model I know all the
dependencies I can get it out and then
once it's running now okay cool i've you
know trained a model to solve this one
very specific problem how do i make it
easier to not reinvent the wheel over
and over and over again it's like any
any company with more than one data
scientist runs into the same issue where
it's like I know I know I have all these
features somewhere in my company but I
don't know where they are and I don't
know which ones will work with you know
with what I'm trying to put the problem
I'm trying to solve so that's one of the
big areas that we're investing in is you
know how do you define an open format
for these reusable modules that you can
stitch together where the inputs are
typed such that I know what types of
data this model will work or this yeah
the module will work against I know what
outputs it produces and then how do I go
and stitch together this graph and then
how do I let somebody else fork the
graph collaborate on the graph with me
and even just take that whole graph and
use it as a module somewhere else so the
pattern we see in you know in being in
office and all these teams doing real
production ml at scale is they have
these huge graphs that are not the work
of one data scientist it's whole teams
who have built feature Iser x' Bilt's
you know modeling techniques built
parameter tuning optimizations and
they're they're all stitched together
and like that's that's how you actually
get the ml lifecycle started I see I'm
gonna go to the high interest credit
card paper now and one of them is
correction Cascades so there are often
situations in which a model a for
problem a exists but a solution for a
slightly different problem a prime is
required in this case it's tempting to
learn from model a prime a that takes a
as an input and learns a small
correction
so you can see here that when you start
to develop this web of interdependencies
between models just to develop this a
bit I want you to articulate your vision
for
company-wide I think of every single
machine learning project as being
independent in in some sense I think of
it as a software project it has an owner
it has an accountable let's say a
product owner and and legally maybe
that's where the accountability lies and
at the company level maybe there's a
model catalog maybe there's a way of
composing and publishing and discovering
these models together I'm not quite sure
how that works
but do you run the risk of if you
publish something who's responsible for
it and do you have this cascade problem
right it's the it's the same problem you
see in software engineering right so we
had this this issue when you know we
call it the one es effort inside of
Microsoft and get everybody onto the
same tools and systems and promote a
culture of internal open-source it's
like okay well internal open-source is
great but you have to introduce the
concept of accountability and ownership
and the lifecycle means you need to be
able to archive and deprecated things or
indicate should you be building on top
of this or not so it's a question of I
have my experiment I want to collaborate
I want to share I want to then so say
I've built a feature Iser I use it for
my tiny thing right but now a huge other
internal team comes and takes a
dependency on it like how do you set up
shared accountability responsibility for
for these modules that you're stitching
together to create these you know the
pipeline's of the ML lifecycle and
that's where I started to talk about Oh
get gets very interesting right so how
do you smoothly bring in get or version
control with the concepts of you know
tagging and labeling and ownership
information and even policies right I
have these modules I've created do I
allow people to take dependencies on any
version of them or like only the version
in master or only the version that's
been tagged because it's been ran
through these 50 different validation
datasets to make sure it works that's
where we're trying to get to is you know
directionally we introduced shareable
modules make it easy to system into
pipelines and then introduce the
the lifecycle on top of the shareable
modules in a seamless way so that you
can go from interactive in a notebook
and ID whatever to in a pipeline to in a
shared pipeline and that's ml obviously
basa so the envisioning might be
something like Doc docker registries for
models or for feature icers for parts of
pipelines exactly there's you know
there's there's docker registries to
capture the dependencies there's
packaged feeds that have the different
libraries that you might want to pull in
there's you know jobs that are
predefined that says hey you know run
this command in this container with this
parameterize data like that's the
layering that we're trying to go for to
make sure that again it's a composable
component is a ball stack that we expose
so how do you think about like when
there's a merge conflict in traditional
software engineering it's usually we
just have written different functions
and then bang we just put them together
it's easy like that but if Tim Forks my
model man Yannick Forks the model they
each training on a different subset of
data how do you merge the network's now
it's an excellent question
so to be able to merge models together
so say I have original pipeline and then
pipeline trained on Tim's dataset a
pipeline trained on Yonex data set B do
you take the same pipeline and run it on
both of the data sets together like just
a feature space over a lap between the
two or do you need to actually run both
pipelines in parallel and then build
some sort of ensemble in technique where
you'll you know run a loop through both
of the models and apply some pre or post
processing to it and on ensembl is also
you know a big thing that we do
internally and we're just starting to
scratch the surface on on model ensemble
sure you could just merge the neural
nets together you can try to fold the
layers together but I think ensemble and
gives you a more sort of flexible way of
doing that because if you think about
you know the way the human brain works
for example
it's not just like one neural-net it's
like every single synapse in your brain
is a different neural net and it played
ensembles all of those together and its
own meta graph and then will spit out a
result just to use the your brain is a
computer analogy they're the solution
that seems obvious to me for this
problem would be like this knowledge
distillation technique where tim's
fork model is gonna label the data then
Yonex fork model is gonna label the data
and i'm gonna train on these to label
distributions now is that something that
like is being thought of as this
technique for merging or because
ensemble intends like well now you have
this collection of models each of each
of them being like you know hundreds of
megabytes of parameters at least right
so do you see knowledge distillation as
being like a useful merge tool for these
networks I think we'll get there
over time I just think this the space
isn't quite advanced enough yet to do it
but ensemble is a cheap way to take
models that were trained on different
data sets and stitch them together well
it's it's cheap from a training point of
view more expensive from an inference
point of view and so that's where you
know we're doing a lot of work on the
Onix side was like the open neural net
exchange to figure out how do you
quantize models and shrink them down so
that they can give you good performance
on the inference side and that that
again that space is still very new
because the frameworks are all evolving
but it's been essential for us to be
able to actually use you know models in
real time like the grammar models in
office because you know you can't spend
five seconds waiting for like
suggestions for sentences to come in
that's just not realistic there's also
the the interesting and when it comes to
a/b testing of models so I have a model
running on the client it's very
expensive to deploy a model down to the
client it's much cheaper to you know run
one in the cloud so how do you do an a/b
test with a model running in two
different places so it's kind of like
your cloud Edge champion challenge or ad
hoc analysis and so
you know one approach we've seen is
you'll have you know different rings you
roll a model out - you can start by
running the model in you know offline
mode or in shadow mode for some time
where you don't block on it the model
can be even you know denser more
expensive to train but you just see sort
of what the fidelity loss looks like
with different techniques of quantizing
the model and that helps you with being
able to use it in production it's also
the question of what you're using the
models for like are they running once a
month okay like who cares like you know
hyper optimizing the latency day it's
not a big deal but if they're running at
5,000 requests a second it's a very very
different problem to go and solve for
you've you've mentioned a bunch of times
right now these these ideas of
strongly-typed
inputs and outputs to these models and
so even if I like okay let's say we
compare Python to C++ or something where
in in C++ i have my strong types and I
know everything's how fit together but
if I look in terms of machine learning
if I do that what's the type of this
thing it's just going to be tensor right
like what that tells me nothing at all
whenever my no IDE can help me there and
even even if you think ahead and say
maybe we can you know the compiler could
track the shapes of the tensors right
and there's like okay 10:05 by through
200 times like sometimes I'll just put
like some weird number as the number of
dimensions or hidden layers so when it
shows up in a tensor like I know oh
that's you know it's this indicator it's
like whereas where you know what I would
want from a typed input would be
something like this thing is an image
that has been normalized something this
technique ran through this sort of
pre-processing right that being the
entire type of the data points how do
you how do you come to that place
so we're very very early here right now
one of the things that we're trying to
do is you know for the major types of
assets in the system so for example like
this is a machine learning model and a
model has a load for has an init
function predict function on top of it
here's some data that goes along with it
here is the environment required to run
it so there's a question of okay the
model is what methods is a model expose
the next 11 the next sort of step there
is what is the schema to the input to
the model right so the the schema could
be like okay this is just you know a
panda's data frame with these columns
inside of it right and so how do you
take a schema of data set flowing in
from haniss whether it's coming from no
json erp see whatever the protocol
happens to be but how do you take that
and translate it into something that's
compatible with like the tensors on the
front
in there and that's we're just
scratching the surface for now for now
what we have is we have I can tell you
you know the scheme of the input
function to this module in the pipeline
and what that looks like from okay it's
a dictionary of you know I expect these
names to come in but we're definitely
not the full granularity of tensors yet
and that's that's something we've been
struggling with and iterating on on the
inference side and so we've released a
public inference schema package but
we're trying to figure out how to tie
that into for example in you know nml
flow and that flow has this model
package format where you define like the
flavor of the model which is how to load
this thing how to run on top of it but
like how do we introduce scheme up those
flavors so we can do that strong typing
and then how do we extend this beyond
just models and to any component inside
of the ml workflow and that's that's the
next step that we're we're working to
get to right now and where we're having
to do that because we have the same
problem for you know explanations right
like an explanation you need to give it
a model and some data as as input so it
can explain the behavior there so it's
because everything is so new and nascent
and there's so many different open
source tools
I don't think standards have emerged
just yet but at least from you know an
azure and Microsoft point of view we're
trying all of them figuring out which
one's work best for our customers both
inside and outside the company and our
net goal is to get to a set of open
interoperable standards for all of this
like we don't know what the shape is
just yet but that is what we're
aggressively pushing towards because we
don't want to have data scientist be
like locked into Azure they should
choose a sure because it's the best
cloud to do their ml work on the subject
of ml flow I used to use ml flow because
it gave me a wonderful interactive work
flow on my machine before I kind of
promoted to
you know as your machine learning and
but you don't need to use ml flow what's
the story that so it's an excellent
question
right now we have you know when it comes
to to logging things in in a job right
you can either use the azure ml SDK or
you can use the ml flow one and we have
you know API parity across across across
the two of them they're both
conceptually born from the same idea
which is how do you enable
reproducibility whether it's through you
know tracking the model package format
or the new work that we're working with
them on for the model registry as well
right so I guess we're we're working on
figuring out the the answer there I have
my thoughts and opinions but I'm curious
what what you guys think like do you
think it makes sense to push
aggressively on an open interoperable
format for logging and tracking or does
it make more sense to you know keep keep
a proprietary one or to use the Azure
machine learning one or to look at other
open source tools or other companies
that are in this space like comet or
weights and biases or Neptune like
there's so many tools in this space like
what do you guys think speaking
personally interoperability and
portability is not that important yeah
the people talked about the need for
cloud portability and so on and most
companies have a multi cloud strategy
and it's completely accepted that you'll
you'll need to do ml things on Azure ml
in a certain way and you'll need to do
say to make is completely different I
think there is a need for global
governance across the entire company for
models but I think that's something
that's slightly different I think every
single project will have its own model
registry and this is what I want to get
your opinion on how does that translate
into company-wide governance so I think
and one of the things we're working on
right now is you know between the Azure
AI and
your data organizations and looking at
open source tools like Apache at lists
how do we enable an enterprise-wide data
catalog that by default includes all of
the modeling work being done so if
anybody you know say create a workspace
create a project whatever I pull in some
data just by pulling it in the data
catalog should know or track like okay
these different projects are now using
this data
anything I output from that data should
also get tracked in the data catalog so
I think you know the while a model
catalog is interesting I think it's
really just models our data and it's
just a subtype of the problem that a
data catalog is trying to solve so you
know from at least my preferences that
we should be collaborating together and
figuring out how to just make models and
and even software applications that
you're rolling out like those those
should all just fall into this
enterprise wide data catalog data
governance life cycle experience could
you just expand a tiny bit on that
because models seem to be slightly less
inert than data because models make
decisions that have consequence and we
were talking about fairness and bias I
mean is the same thing applies to data
right people make decisions on data that
has consequences so I don't think
they're actually that different it's
like a model is just some transformed
data you may have read a bunch of
features or feature answers on it you
may have run some different modeling
techniques on it but fundamentally it's
some data that you spat out and it's
gonna have the same problems as any
other type of data you're dealing with
but is there a difference the model is
the function not the data you can put
data through the model does that make a
meaningful difference in your opinion I
think to a to an extent there I guess
the big thing is a model is a
combination of the data and the function
to run on the data right
so it's really more than a data catalog
it's a data and feature and model
catalog that you can look at all of that
together and then see all of the
different jobs whether it's just a data
processing job or a model development
pipeline or an inference my plan that
are using those assets because that's
the whole sticking point of ML versus
normal software engineering is you're
introducing data like that's that's
where all of the complexity comes from
right like code code is a commodity data
is gold so when you put when you put
gold in your applications all of a
sudden things start to matter a lot more
what kind of things would you record in
this catalog I'm I'm thinking that data
has very important dimensions around
privacy for example right and it's not
necessarily structured data it's even
harder if it's unstructured data because
how do you possibly record useful
semantic information exactly and so
right now the things we're looking at
capturing is what is the intended use
for this data like what is the source of
this data what is the the PII level of
this data we have this problem in an
office when we're training models so say
I want to train a model on top of email
data well if I want an interactive
experience I can either use public
domain email data so like the Enron
emails or you know the Hillary Clinton
email data sets those are pretty popular
ones internally there or there's you
know semi eyes on where if for example
internal Microsoft employees opt in then
I can run training jobs on top of those
or I can even extract my own emails and
train emails on top of those but then as
you go you know further and further into
the p.i level the PII level gets higher
the question is how do you how do you
even do training on confidential data
and we've built a bunch of tools
internally and we're actually in the
process of open sourcing those right now
to enable you to to do things like log
scrubbing where you can scrub PII out of
your training jobs or enable you to do
model training and a detonation chamber
on top of compliant data so I can shape
my training pipeline on the public
domain data refine it further on mine
then start applying it to you know a
real enterprise data set corpus and
provide the security to your larger
company customer whatever that their
real data isn't leaking out because you
just train on the train on the samples
or on a subset they're one extension of
that is and there are some announcements
that build last week and maybe you can
expand on these as well that there's
something called Microsoft seal which is
this homomorphic encryption methodology
for scenarios when you can kind of allow
data scientists or third parties before
memo on encrypted sensitive data there's
also something announced called white
noise which is a new approach to
differential privacy where you kind of
like randomly add add noise to certain
records so you can no longer be sure
that it was their contribution in the
model so Microsoft is doing some pretty
cool stuff that definitely we have huge
investments internally externally and
we're trying to as much as possible take
the goodness and push it out to open
source as soon as we can because we know
from you know all of our customers are
asking for this and at least from my
point of view I want to make sure that
we're building in a way that customers
can use it right away and not like you
know which doesn't lock responsible AI
behind a paywall that to me is just the
wrong approach to take so let's say I've
hacked into your email system and I have
your model copies before and after you
go and train locally on Tim's emails and
I want to reconstruct Tim's emails that
you've just trained on do you think
there would be any way that I could have
optimized directly to have a generative
model try to produce data that causes
that change I think generative
adversarial models are super interesting
there so that's another validation sweep
you can do is say I have this neural net
to run basically run a scanner that
scans through the whole neural net tries
throwing common use cases in or tries to
see if it can extract anything PII from
it so yeah just basic example is an
organizational
acronym dictionary let's say you're
training a model for a company talking
about their quarterly earnings reports
if you start to learn what those
acronyms mean and you can reverse
engineer it then you're kind of in
trouble and you're eroding customer
choice on top of it because then you
know anybody with access to to that
model inside the company could then
start running things and try to figure
out like okay what's what's changing
over time so that that whole space is
gonna be very very interesting to watch
evolve on the adversarial ml adversarial
AI especially because you know as as Tim
alluded to I think deep learning is
becoming more and more prevalent by the
day classic it classic ml for most
customers is where they're starting but
they all want to use deep learning but
none of them can use it until we have
these these types of responsibilities I
tools you think there will be like sort
of like you have black cats right now
for classic like for servers and so on
there there might be emerging an
emerging class of a black hat hacker for
4ml models like public sleep publicly
exposed models you already see things
like this we we have teams internally
that do exactly this right so we have
teams that will go and look at the
models and do threat modeling threat
analysis on top of them and we have seen
yeah and the even even in the external
community trying to hack into companies
machine learning platforms to figure out
what they're doing what data their
models are trained on but that's going
to be the you know the next generation
of black hats are gonna be the data
scientist of black hats
hosted so Jordan it's been an absolute
honor to have you on the show this week
but before you go do you have any
exciting announcements or anything else
that you want to let our viewers know
nothing at the moment where we're
cooking up a lot of really cool stuff
internally obviously kovat is set back
some of that and when it's going to be
announced and rolled out but let's let's
grab some more time in a month or two
and maybe we can even show you some of
the cool stuff we're working on oh that
would be an absolute honor just
to finish things off if you could go
back in time and give you a younger self
some advice what would it be oh stop
trying to talk data scientist out of
using Jupiter notebooks yes that is what
I should do the same thing that's a
wonderful advice Jordan is it's been a
pleasure thank you so much for coming on
the show and we look forward to getting
you back on yeah thanks for having me
this is great guys thanks so much bye I
really hope you enjoyed the session
today remember to Like comment and
subscribe and we will see you back for
another exciting episode next week